thank you to curiosity stream for
sponsoring this video hi there so in a
video that I just uploaded on my channel
I was looking through this exam paper
it's from 1866 so it's very old and it
was interesting to see some of the
arithmetic questions that were asked
back then why don't this stand out
difficult questions or at least what I
would consider difficult was this one
here number 20 what is the square root
of zero point zero zero four three zero
four six seven two one now finding the
square root of this without a calculator
which they wouldn't have had back then
there's something that strikes me as
quite difficult because I've never
really had to do this in exam situations
during my small amount of research I
found that some countries still get
students to improve that they can do
these things without a calculator the
merit of having to prove such things
without calculators even though we can
do it on the calculator I guess is up to
debate but today I'm going to just work
through this problem and see how you
actually do this if you are stranded
somewhere without any fault from
Mishima's so first of all just a tiny
bit of theory that might come in handy
to understand the steps here essentially
we're going to use an algorithm to solve
the square root and it's one that you
can do by hand but it comes from the
idea that we're going to approximate the
square root and if we say that our
proximation at any point is given by x
but it's not the best approximation and
we can do better we want to find an x
plus r so that this whole value is less
then the square root that we're trying
to find so we don't want to over
approximate we want our guesses to
remain below the square root we're
essentially approaching it from
Lode so every time we add on an
hour-to-hour proximation it should get
closer and closer from below now if we
take this inequality and just
essentially do some algebra on it we can
shift the square root over to the side
we can expand the side
and then we can vectorize a different
part of it
now this last line of written you might
wonder where it came from but it is
actually the algorithm that we're going
to use to essentially better our
approximations to find the square root
let's have a look at it in practice and
then you might understand a little
better where it's come from first let's
just write down our number
and what we're going to start with is
for every digit after the decimal point
we're going to group them in groups of
two so just put a line over each group
of two to group them up there that will
just help us alright so to start with we
want to find a number whose square is
less than or equal to the first pair of
numbers however we're going to skip over
the string of zeros here we're just
going to put zeros here and start with
our first sort of real digits here the 4
and a 3 if you are familiar with your
squares you would know that 6 squared is
36 7 squared is 49 so 6 squared is the
biggest square that is less than this
one here so let's put down a 6
now since 6 squared was 36 we're going
to write that down below and we're going
to subtract that from 43 so if we do
that subtraction the difference will be
7 now let's bring down our next set of
two numbers it's a 0 and a 4 so we've
got 704 here we're going to put a line
in here and then what we're going to do
is take our previous number and double
it so 2 times 6 is 12
but then we've also left a little death
in here because this is going to be a
hundred and twenty something and we want
to find what this digit should be such
that a hundred and twenty something
times that something is less than or
equal to 704 so for example we could try
a hundred and twenty-five times five and
see what that is equal to I find that
trying the five first of all is a good
place to start because you can see if
you need to go higher
lower a hundred and twenty five times
five actually works out to be six
hundred and twenty five and you can do
that off in the margins with a
reasonably simple multiplication by hand
so that's 625 that qualifies because
it's under here we best try what 126
times six is just to be sure and 126
times six is 756 so it's over so
actually we're going to be using five as
our final answer in here we'll also put
a five up the top to record it now this
might have looked kind of random but it
kind of comes from this algorithm step
here where we were taking two times our
previous guests plus a new our timesing
that all by our and it has to be less
than or equal to what we're trying to
find the square root of minus x squared
so we've been - along the way here let's
just continue with this tip that we went
through we're just going to keep
iterating it until we sort of get to the
end of our numbers now 125 times five
like I said was 625 so we'll just
subtract that from 704 what we'll get is
79 and then we'll bring down the next
two numbers which are a6 and a7 again
let's find the this number times 265
times 2 is going to be a hundred and
thirty and then we'll leave a little gap
here so we can see one thousand three
hundred and something times that
something has to be less than or equal
to this here so we could start by trying
five again one thousand three hundred
and five times five that would be six
thousand five hundred and twenty-five
it's a little low so we'll keep trying
we'll go a bit higher we'll try one
thousand three hundred and six times six
and that would be seven thousand eight
hundred and thirty six now that's as
close as we're going to get so six is
going to be what we'll use here and more
Recorder six up there subtract these two
from each other
do we get here at 131 bring down our
last two numbers which are a 2 and a 1
take this number six five six and double
it when we do that it's one three one
two leave a space for a digit and then
13,000 120 something times something
will be less than or equal to this well
actually this is very close to this
already if we just had a 1 in there
13,000 121 times 1 will give us this
exactly so 1 will be our last digit and
because we don't have any remainders
left over here if we wouldn't you know
do it like we were doing before this
would be 0 you've actually reached the
end of our process and this value here
0.06 5 6 1 is the square root of what we
were trying to work out so in practice
it actually isn't too difficult the
working is only this big but to get here
you have to sort of know this little
algorithm and often the margin you have
to try several attempts at multiplying
things until you get was right I'd like
to thank curiosity stream for sponsoring
this video
curiosity stream are a subscription
streaming service that offers over 2000
documentaries and nonfiction titles from
some of the world's best filmmakers
including some exclusive originals you
can get unlimited access starting at
just $2.99 a month or for my audience
the first 30 days are completely free if
you sign up at curiosity stream comm
slash tibbie's and use the promo code
tibbie's during the signup process i'm
really looking forward to watching the
secret life of chaos it explores the
mathematics of chaos theory and how it
can explain why the universe creates
order and pattern
thanks curiosity stream also thank you
to my patrons who support me on page
and thank you for watching